les images de l'annnonce de la
nomination de jean françois lépine bien
sûr notre ancien camarade ici à radio
canada 1 qui a été correspondant en
chine pendant quatre ans à la fin des
années 80 il retournera en chine
non pas comme le délégué mais comme le
nouveau représentant du québec à
shanghai
je lui parlais à quelques minutes soit
lépine bonsoir à vous dans sa patrie
alors nommé c'est pas délégué ses
directeurs des bureaux en chine acteur
dans le présent du québec en chine pour
une simple raison c'est que là les
bureaux en chine pour l'instant n'ont
pas de statut de délégation
c'est des raisons de protocole entre la
chine et le québec ont repris du mandat
dans une seconde mais d'abord changement
de vie et du temps pour vous hein
comment ça s'est fait comme ça
patrice est que depuis que j'ai quitté
radio canada j'ai beaucoup travaillé
avec les entreprises québécoises le
projet que j'avais c'était de démarrer
une société qu'on a démarré à huîtres
internationale pour aider les
entreprises qui veulent se développer
dans les marchés émergents parce que je
crois fondamentalement que le québec a
besoin de ça pour s'enrichir profiter de
la croissance mondiale cette
opportunité-là extraordinaire arrive
avec un mandat qu'on a défini ensemble
pour accroître la présence du québec sur
le plus gros marché au monde et je pense
que c'est important d'y être à ce moment
ici en particulier au moment où la chine
traversent une période particulière et
quels objectifs vous vous donnez pas
c'est tellement grand et va justement
vous avez choisi non pas de vous essayer
à pékin et à shanghai pour ben donc il
fallait choisir un lieu un de parmi ces
parce que ces trois bureaux on ouvre
aussi une antenne ce qu'on appelle une
antenne c'est un bureau de départ dans
la province du shandong qui est une
province avec laquelle le québec à une
entente une très grosse province de près
de 100 millions d'habitants très
important il fallait choisir un lieu et
la plupart des entreprises puisqu'on
parle de 100 canadienne ou québécoise
qui sont établis en chine sont au tour
de chant grâce et la plus grande quand
on y pense régions économiques ces 200
millions d'habitants autour du grand
shanghai
c'est le silicon valley chinois en plus
du centre financier de chine autour dans
cette grande région là
et c'était le mandat de deux des bureaux
du québec en chine c'est d'abord
économique c'est d'abord de développer
les relations entre le québec et la
chine sur le plan des échanges
économiques dans le domaine de
l'éducation la culture et c'était
beaucoup plus efficace de s'établir là
en tant que patron des bureaux il ya des
affaires à brasser en chine ça c'est une
évidence
est ce que le fait que vous soyez là bas
quelle mesure ça va aider dans quelle
mesure un homme peut aider oui c'est
tellement un marché tout à fait d'abord
encore une fois on se définit des
objectifs donc on veut augmenter la
présence à terme on le commence déjà par
l'ouverture d'un bureau dans cette
province là on veut exploiter aussi les
relations bilatérales qui ont 30 ans
entre montréal et shanghai le québec
aussi à houcine entend depuis 2011 avec
cette ville donc un partenariat avec
cette ville donc ce qui va être notre
point d'entrée maintenant les relations
internationales se conçoivent beaucoup
en terme de vies la ville où les grands
univers urbain sont des cibles beaucoup
plus facile à atteindre vous l'avez dit
qu un pays d'un milliard 4 il est ce que
vous visez une mission économique québec
où une émission économique montréal
chanrai bien tout ce qui a des objectifs
concrets et invité le prochain pays il
va y avoir d'abord toute une série de
visites ministérielles je peux pas vous
voulez dire tout de suite parce que vous
savez que c'est complexe faut que les
chinois acceptent faut que tout le monde
a accès mais on parle pas seulement de
ça moi je veux par exemple et ça c'est
une partie de mon mandat important de
faire une synergie entre d'abord les
organismes québécois qui sont là la
caisse de dépôt qui est en chine de
façon très importante on l'a vu encore
récemment
investissement québec les entreprises
privées québécoises regardé par
cooperation qui est une entreprise qui
devient lumière quarantaine d'années qui
a des contacts au plus haut niveau en
chine
moi je veux qu'il ya une synergie très
importante entre tous les intervenants
québécois sur place pour qu'on soit
beaucoup plus efficace et puis que les
le privé s'unissent avec le québec dans
des opérations sur le plan en y
contribuant financièrement a lancé la
visibilité qu'on veut acroître mais
aussi une autre partie de mon mandat
c'est de venir ici au québec beaucoup
parlé aux entreprises parler aux
organisations pour l'exemple vial collet
convaincre celles temps d'y aller
que si on n'est pas là on rate le bateau
par ailleurs la chine inquiète
actuellement les voix de façon razr et
ans depuis hier qu'est ce que vous en
dites vous de la situation économique
est ce que il n'ya pas un déclin l'a
tellement qu'on est monté au d'abord
quand on connaît lé tout ce qui a été
écrit tout ce qui a été dit sur la chine
c'est sûr que la croissance à 10% on
savait que ça se terminerait on pensait
que ça stabiliserait vers l'es7
peut-être 6%
la chaîne est en train de faire un
tournant actuellement je le résume
rapidement mais d'une économie qui
pendant 30 ans a fait ce succès
faramineux basé essentiellement sur
l'exportation
mais ça ça devient insoutenable quand on
exporte des chemises le bangladesh peut
en faire le vietnam peut en faire un
moment donné il ya une concurrence qui
devient féroce et la chine devaient
c'était prévu se serait retourné vers
son marché intérieur un milliard quatre
cent mille ce que les japonais ont fait
dans les années 70 on relève l'économie
rainer relance moyens gouvernement pour
qu elles mêmes prennent le relais donc
ce marché là deviennent le moteur de
croissance
on est en plein dans cette transition là
ça se fait pas facilement et c'était
prévu et être présent encore une fois
avec un représentant au dit ça fait une
différence tout à fait ça fait une
différence à nous permettre d'expliquer
aux gens ici ce qui se passe davantage
les rassurer et puis il ya un message à
passer en chine non moi je suis un
expert en communication
c'est ça qu'on fait dans le métier que
j'ai fait pendant 40 ans on communique
des messages il ya un aspect très
important de mon métier qui va de
communiquer aux chinois vraiment ce
qu'est le québec il ya toute sorte de
clan de ce côté là que je devrais pas
parler immédiatement mais qui vont faire
en sorte que l'image du québec va être
plus frappante en chine près on veut
profiter de tous les québécois qui
seront là en tout cas si vous connaissez
bien la chaîne d'alerté correspondant
kouassi ça comme j'étais correspondant
presque quatre ans à l'époque mais ça
fait longtemps mais surtout c'est que je
suis retourné régulièrement dernier
c'est probablement ça qui a fait en
sorte que comment votre recrue chinois
très bien fait genre ouais bon ben là
c'est réglé d'ailleurs c'est la seule
nomination je crois qui a été fait par
le gouvernement couillard était saluée
par exactement ce début moi aussi dans
soit le gossip alors
vraiment intéressante en tout cas ça
m'indique quelque chose c'est que les
gens considèrent que c'est un choix dans
les circonstances qui est juste déçu
et puis vous allez voir je pense que les
projets mentionnés en provenance de
chine on va vous aussi mal que des
québécois qui doivent s'ouvrir davantage
au monde vont venir en plus grand nombre
jean françois lépine bonne chose nouveau
mandat merci beaucoup c'est moi qui va
là